have you ever felt smug after pirating a
piece of software
of course you know that you shouldn't be
pirating and you might even partially
feel bad about doing it but at the same
time you were able to get one over on
industry giants like microsoft and adobe
who have tens of thousands of employees
trying to stop you or do they companies
obviously do not want you to pirate
their software and i'm not endorsing
piracy by any means but with that being
said most companies don't actually make
it that difficult to pirate their
software
in fact the reason you were able to get
your hands on a pirated piece of
software likely has less to do with the
talent of the hacker you got it from and
more to do with the company letting you
get away with it and here's why
before we jump into why many companies
turn a blind eye to piracy let's take a
look at how easy it would be for
companies to make their software nearly
impossible to crack
one of the easiest ways companies can
prevent piracy is by making their
software critically reliant on their own
servers take a look at something like
clash royale or fortnite these games are
free so there's no reason to pirate them
but even if they cost money pirating the
software itself would basically be
useless you won't be able to play these
games without accessing the company's
servers and it's basically impossible to
access their servers without a
legitimate copy of the game another
example of this is streaming services
like netflix and disney plus downloading
the netflix or disney plus app is not
going to let you access any of their
content now of course i'm sure there are
crazy hackers around the world who have
managed to get past these servers but
these work rounds never become popular
online because the second it does the
companies will patch it another simple
way companies can shut down piracy is
through encryption and tamper proofing
tamper proof software will instantly
shut down and stop working the second
that the source code is modified
companies can throw on some encryption
on top of this to make it extremely
difficult for hackers to even decrypt
what is written in the source code let's
say a hacker spent six months decrypting
the software and then working around the
tamper tamper-proofing the second the
hacker shares it online the company can
look at how the hacker worked around the
system after that they can switch
encryption protocols and patch the crack
basically overnight it would take them a
week at max to raise 6 months of the
hacker's work at this point the hacker
is just helping the company improve its
security protocol for free
as you can see it's not that hard for
companies to make their software nearly
impenetrable
and many of the biggest companies around
us do exactly this when was the last
time you heard of someone pirating ios
or the bloomberg terminal or autocad or
blackrock's aladdin when was the last
time the iphone's passcode lock was
cracked i mean it literally took the fbi
themselves 13 years to crack the iphone
passcode lock they did eventually get it
though so i'm not saying that it's
impossible but companies can easily make
it nearly impossible and many companies
do
yet 91 percent of pcs sold in india run
on a pirated copy of windows 10 and 58
of all photoshop users use pirated
software so what's up with this well the
first reason many companies turn a blind
eye to piracy is that they treat it like
a low-cost investment when bill gates
was asked about his thoughts on piracy
he responded to the prevalence of piracy
was terrible but at the same time he
also said that tolerating piracy turned
out to be microsoft's best long-term
strategy here's the thing whenever
someone pirates a piece of software they
get used to the software whether that be
photoshop or microsoft office
they might use the pirated software for
years but eventually there will come a
time that the company comes out with a
new version of the software
at this point the pirate has become
pretty accustomed to the software and
it's safe to assume that they desire the
new version of the software they have
the option to power the new version or
they can buy the real thing
95 of these users will likely just
pirate the software once again
but a solid few percent will buy it the
second time around
maybe they got value from the software
and they feel morally obligated to pay
for it or maybe they're just tired of
dealing with all the bugs associated
with the pirated software whatever the
reason a small portion of these users
will become paid users with every
software cycle
and while it's not a fast process when
you're dealing with billions of people
and decades of time it doesn't add up
take india for example currently there
are 845 million internet users in india
if we assume that half of these users
access the internet using windows we get
420 million people given that 91 of
these users have a pirated version of
windows we're dealing with about 380
million people even if just two percent
of these users convert to legal users
that's 7.6 million additional users if
microsoft releases to windows versions
per decade we're looking at 15.2 million
new customers every decade
something else to consider is that the
main reason people pirate software is
because they can't afford it in the us
the piracy rate is only 19
which is a far cry from the 91 in india
but when you think about it it's way
easier for americans to pirate software
they're generally more familiar with
computers they have better internet
access and they have more resources
yet most americans do not pirate
software because they see it as more of
a hassle as opposed to a way to save
money when you're spending thousands of
hours on your computer every year it
makes sense to spend some extra cash and
secure a legitimate version of windows
unfortunately most people in india and
china do not currently have the luxury
of doing this but this will change
as these countries transition from being
emerging countries to being developed
countries there will be an influx of
people buying legitimate software
in other words the percentage of pirates
who transition to being paying users
won't stay at two percent forever it'll
become five 10 15
and the piracy rates in these countries
will eventually reach levels similar to
the us
at that point microsoft and adobe and
all the companies that use this strategy
would literally capture billions of
customers who would have otherwise never
even tried the software and i think bill
gates says it best as long as they're
going to steal it we want them to steal
ours
i sort of sort of get addicted and then
we somehow figure out how to how to
collect sometime in the next
in the next decade so you know it's a
great great place to be involved in now
this strategy does not work for every
company or every product and that's why
some companies prefer to keep their
software difficult to pirate for example
the bloomberg terminal costs two
thousand dollars per month letting
people pass the terminal isn't going to
do bloomberg any good as basically none
of the pirates will ever become
legitimate users at those prices
similarly apple makes money by selling
iphones not selling ios if they let
people easily get their hands on ios
more people may become addicted to ios
and end up buying an iphone but this
would also make the ios experience not
unique and tailored to iphones which
would go against apple's branding so
apple usually tends to regulate piracy
quite strictly anyway the other reason
that some companies take it easy on
pirates is market share
at the end of the day even if a pirate
doesn't translate to a paying user that
pirate is still one less user that your
competitor does not have in the case of
microsoft minimizing the number of
people using the competition was
particularly important due to the
existence of linux many people swear by
linux and claim that it's way better
than windows i've never used linux but
considering that microsoft gave in on
the cloud market and uses linux to run
azure i think it's pretty safe to assume
that linux is quite good
even if linux is only 70 or 80 as good
as windows when you consider that linux
is free linux blows windows out of the
water
if microsoft didn't make it easy to get
away with pirating windows the first
thing users would have done is go with
linux
today android has a 95 market share in
india and i suspect that linux would
hold a very similar market share today
across developing countries if windows
was hard to pirate aside from deterring
customers from going to the current
competition companies are able to
prevent new competition from springing
up altogether
take adobe for example their creative
software suite is arguably the best on
the market but it's also quite expensive
this creates a great opportunity for
potential competitors to make a second
grade product that's substantially
cheaper however given the relative ease
of powering adobe software very few
consumers would consider it anything
else you either pirate premiere pro or
you pay for it there is no middle ground
apple has been able to carve out a
decent market share for themselves with
the final cut pro thanks to their loyal
fan base and tailored software
but everyone else like sony vegas
basically got cut out and that brings us
to the final reason that some companies
tolerate piracy which is alternate modes
of monetization as the internet and
technology continue to advance we see
more and more creative methods to
monetize users i mean just take a look
at google and facebook all the services
they offer are free to the end user yet
they're both trillion dollar companies
just because someone didn't pay to use
windows doesn't mean that microsoft
can't make any money from that user
microsoft doesn't sell user data but
they do leverage user data for targeted
advertising which of course makes the
money
at the end of the day pirating is a
crime and you should not do it with that
being said though companies realize that
there will always be a market that's
looking to get software for free
some companies block out this market by
making it nearly impossible to pirate
their software
this makes sense for commercial projects
that are mainly used by corporations and
institutions when it comes to consumer
products however tolerating piracy is
often beneficial for the company long
term tolerating piracy allows for
software to be exposed around the world
and it makes it extremely difficult for
competitors to carve out market share
hopefully these pirates eventually turn
into paying customers but even if they
don't companies have figured out several
alternative methods to monetize these
users and to minimize losses
now again none of this gives you a free
pass to pirate software but this is why
some companies tolerate pirating and why
you're not a genius for pirating
software the ease was by design have you
guys ever pirated any software comment
i'm clean if you have also drop a like
if you're grateful for microsoft and
adobe's policy of toleration
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one